new fallout for president Trump over a
whistleblower complaint about his
contact with a Ukrainian leader former
Vice President Joe Biden is now firing
back at the president after mr. Trump
reportedly pressed the Ukrainian
president to investigate Biden's son
Paula Reid is at the White House Paula
what can you tell us a good morning
Michelle the former vice president is
demanding the White House release any
transcripts of calls with the Ukraine
last night president Trump and the First
Lady hosted a state dinner for the Prime
Minister of Australia but all the pomp
and pageantry could not distract from
the controversy surrounding the White
House this week the show went on at the
White House Friday night as president
Trump and the First Lady hosted the
australian prime minister and his wife
for a state dinner
meanwhile the president's personal
attorney rudy guiliani laughed off
questions about his contentious
interview with CNN where he admitted to
pressuring the Ukrainian government to
look into the Biden family you did ask
Ukraine to look into job I of course I
did
CBS News has learned the president's
outreach to Ukraine is at the center of
a whistleblower complaint filed by a
former intelligence official the
specific details of the complaint are
not known as the Justice Department and
the White House have blocked it from
being handed over to Congress arguing
the president is outside the scope of
the intelligence community's Inspector
General sitting alongside the Australian
Prime Minister earlier in the day
president Trump defended his dealings
with world leaders I've had
conversations with many leaders that
always appropriate
I thinks God can tell you that always
appropriate at the highest level always
appropriate and anything I do I fight
for this country
I fight so strongly for this country
it's just another political hack job at
the center of the whistleblowers
complaint is reportedly a phone call the
President had with the Ukrainian leader
on July 25th the Ukrainian government
says they discussed completing
investigation of corruption cases
according to The Wall Street Journal mr.
Trump pressured the Ukrainian president
eight times to investigate former Vice
President Joe Biden's son hunter who
worked for a Ukrainian gas company
during the Obama administration
one single credible outlet has given any
credibility to his assertion not one see
the one while campaigning in Iowa Biden
first dismissed any wrongdoing and so I
have no comment except the president
start to rock but he later fired back
writing in a statement such clear-cut
corruption damages and diminishes our
government by making them tools of a
personal political vendetta House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi says this
whistleblowers complaint raises urgent
national security concerns Democrats are
also investigating if the president
tried to withhold military aid from the
Ukraine in an effort to pressure it
to investigate the Biden's but so far
there is no evidence proving that's what
happened Jeff okay Paula thank you very
much